je ne suis pas un tueur à gage je me
vois plus comme un
nettoyeur
exactement je dois convaincre quelqu'un
que le corps qui se trouve dans ce
coffre est bien celui de Rollo il a été
défiguré il n'a plus de visage en fait
il n'a plus de tête du
tout c'est curieux la
trahison ça vous prend tout le temps au
dépourvu
jamais entendu parler des sonnes vidéo
on se fait
[Musique]
attaquer j'ai
tous
g
plus
ces 50000 dollars pourrai vraiment
changer ma vie et je les trouverai avec
ou sans
[Musique]
vous Charlie Swift j'ai plus d'hommes
que tu n'as de balles les balles c'est
facile à
trouver qu'est-ce que tu veux que tu
cesses de respirer et comment tu vas t'y
prendre c'est en
cours vous devriez commencer à songer à
une porte de sortie
et vous attendez quoi je t
vois ça
commence pas faire les choses à
moié cétait mon deè meilleur gars et
bien j'ai de rencontrer le numéro
for a long
time